[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive coming up we'll see
what's making the headlines with
columnist at the article ali mirage and
journalist and author
christina patterson there they are ready
and waiting to go so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
well the prime minister gave his
clearest signal so far today that the
easing of restrictions due on june the
21st
will be delayed that's according to the
telegraph
the express asks if we will ever be free
of social distancing regulations
while the observer focuses on the g7
summit and what it
describes as boris johnson's
extraordinary public spat
with eu leaders over the northern
ireland protocol
government ministers should be banned
from lobbying for up to
five years after leaving office in the
wake of the green sill scandal
that's in the sunday times the star
leads on the miracle of ex-spurs
midfielder christian erickson's
treatment after collapsing
during the denmark finland euros fixture
tonight
which is a virtually the same front page
for
the sunday mirror
and we're joined tonight by ali mirage
and christina
patterson good evening to you both and
we're going to start with that uh
telegraph front page
and uh the headline there that there are
fears that the restrictions could be in
place
until the spring certainly the prime
minister speaking to our political
editor beth
rigby has hinted at that today christina
well i must say even for someone who's
uh known for being
pretty uh realistic about these things
that came a bit of a shock
um i think i think the delay is not much
of a shock
to anyone clearly boris johnson was very
keen to stick
to to keep his word on this but it was
always meant to be
dependent on data and the so-called
delta variant has changed everything
it's
unbelievably infectious it seems to be
64 percent
more transmissible than the kent variant
which was considerably more
transmissible than the original variant
which means that each person could
infect up to
seven people which is very bad news
because there are still
a lot of unvaccinated people um a lot of
youngsters have not yet had their
opportunity to have a first vaccine let
alone a second one
and unfortunately people with just one
vaccine
are being hospitalized at the moment and
quite a lot of them
are quite young so he clearly felt he
had no choice but to do this
um and you know it seems like sensible
thing to do obviously it hasn't been
confirmed but
if we really do have to have
restrictions till spring that
is pretty depressing i have to say ali
is it the sensible
thing to do the predictions are that
this is the announcement that he will
make
on monday not necessarily at this time
scale but it won't be june the 21st
well julian it might be the sensible
thing to do but i think the government
needs to be clear about
what metrics it's using to make these
decisions i mean
i thought that dean zahari had made it
quite clear that there were a number of
factors the vaccination rate
the new k the number of new cases the
hospitalization rate and then the death
rate were meant to be
driving this process but also also one
of the one of the criteria where
the um the new variants and that
had to be taken into consideration which
is at play in this instance
indeed and the new variants as well but
we don't know exactly julian what
metrics beyond those they're actually
basing these decisions
off and therefore you could have another
variant coming down the track in a few
weeks that hasn't even been
seen yet so how long is this going to go
on so i think
we understand if we understand that the
government needs to be careful it made a
lot of missteps early on in this
uh crisis it has found the path to
redemption through vaccination which is
all very
positive and good um and he doesn't want
to jeopardize that however
we also do need to get the economy back
on track
we have uh 2 trillion of public debt we
have 350 billion
of borrowing this year and we can't
indefinitely go on like this so
i think the prime minister is going to
have a lot of pressure from certain
elements of his back benches we know the
coved recovery group
has been on maneuvers mark harper and
the gang uh graham brady the chairman of
the 1922 committee annie and duncan
smith the former leader of the
conservative party
all being very strong but how long can
this actually go on for
uh it's important to get the economy
back up and running and speaking from a
personal perspective
as a part-time house music dj i would
love to get back into nightclubs
uh when it's safe to do so as soon as
possible ali that's something i didn't
know about you
there you go you learn something every
day um
christina though on that point um but
what do you think of the the argument
that really we have to
start getting on with with life and even
if
new variants do appear we have to be
able to to deal with them
and we simply can't just shut down
forever
well we can't shut down forever that's
true and by the way i am not
a dj though that doesn't surprise me
i do i must say i do massively miss
parties socializing it's wonderful to be
able to see
a few friends again but i'm a party girl
i you know i used to go out every night
i do
massively miss normal life i think a lot
of people
seem to think that those of us who are
being cautious are kind of pro
lock down hardly i think everybody hates
lockdown it's causing terrible damage to
people's mental health
to lots of people's physical health and
of course to the economy but i think the
calculations that are being made are
literally about the nhs
and um i think that my understanding is
that boris johnson has seen modeling
that shows that within a month
um if he released on the 21st of
june as originally planned then
hospitals would be closed to collapse
again because
uh there will be so many people uh
hospitalized and as we know there are
twice
the uh chances of being hospitalized are
twice as high
uh with this variant as with the
previous and a lot of younger people so
i mean gosh we just have to hope that by
the time
it's another four weeks uh with many
more people doubly vaccinated
that it will be manageable from the
point of view of the nhs and that we can
control our borders more effectively
so we don't get uh too many awful new
variants coming in but you know
clearly nobody knows at the moment and
we'll just have to do what the nhs
allows us
to do yeah yeah indeed uh let's talk uh
brexit ally the observer front page and
uh
boris johnson in quite bellicose mode
really from the g7
indeed i mean we know that uh
marshmallows were being toasted
on the fire pit of harvest bay tonight
but unfortunately all is not well
and it's not well because of this whole
issue around the northern ireland
protocol
and the movement of chicken nuggets
sausages and cold meat uh from uh great
britain to northern ireland
uh and the question is whether they
should be frozen or not uh according to
eu regulations this is all comes
uh within the northern ireland protocol
boris johnson is
being very clear about the fact that he
might invoke article 16
which will allow him to extend this um
grace period at the moment which would
uh allow these movements to happen i
think three things really are at stake
here
one is the internal integrity of the uh
uk the territorial integrity of the uk
the second
is the integrity of the eu single market
which is very important to them
and the third is the sanctity of the
good friday agreement which
was always about not having a hard
border on the island of ireland but the
problem is
that you've got a situation where a lot
of unionists in northern ireland
over 50 of people in northern ireland
what the northern ireland protocol scrap
we know that we're now entering the
marching season which is always
a little bit of a challenging time
anyway so there may be unrest on the
streets we've already seen unrest a few
weeks ago
so this is dangerous and then we had
emmanuel macron today
really a red rag bull to the prime
minister saying that
northern ireland was not really part of
the uk
when uh the prime minister said how
would you feel about sausages not being
able to be moved from toulouse to paris
and macron saying that well that
wouldn't happen because um
you know it's part of the same country
and the northern ireland is part of the
uk
and and certainly boris johnson is upset
about it the question is
now what happens is there going to be a
trade war is there going to be
retaliation here
we know that joe biden is really worried
about this as well ali the
the prime minister says a trade war
highly likely so uh
it uh remains to be seen how this is uh
concluded uh for the minute thank you
both uh we're going to take a break but
coming up
leave your personal politics at home the
message to more than 100 oxford
university lecturers threatening to
boycott classes
over a controversial statute stay with
us
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
philip no
go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christchurch has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
fun
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
lay
i am tonitiv the founder and the ceo of
renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
in my whole life my mission is simple is
to bring back power
to africa and our vision is to turn the
dark continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
2014.
[Applause]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me
of the economist at the article ali
mirage and journalist and author
christina
patterson welcome back to both of you
christine let's start with you
in this section and have a look at the
sunday telegraph
and this is a piece about lecturers
particularly at
oxford keeping politics out of the
lectures
yes lord wharton has written to
the academics who are protesting
and refusing to lecture because of the
roads
the cecil rhodes statues still being
there
at oriole college and basically said
keep your own politics
out of lectures and i must say i think
on balance i'm with him on this one i
look the statues thing is complicated
and i think
following the black lives matter
demonstrations and that
last summer and the movement that's
followed from that i think it's
absolutely right
that many statues of
men who have been and they are all men
let's be clear
who have been given a an elevated
position in history
in spite of their a past based on
the exploitation and sale of human
beings
i think they should not remain in that
elevated position
and i know that the government is very
keen to stoke culture wars because they
think it will
appeal to their new red wall voters who
they seem to
think are uh racist uh they're certainly
traditional but i think it's pretty
i think it's pretty insulting to assume
that they are racist and that seems to
be one of the assumptions that's made
but on the other hand i think you can go
too far in bringing your
own political views into your
workplace there are plenty of things we
don't necessarily like about
um our employers about their histories
and nobody has
an entirely pure history most companies
have been built on exploitation or one
for of one form or another and so have
most
historic institutions so i think
probably the academics should
concentrate on students who've had a
really tough time who paid a lot of
money
for experiences they haven't had okay
over the past
okay just want to get ali's thoughts on
on this
look i think it's a it's a difficult one
but i think that there are dangers in
judging people
uh by today's standards when they
operated in a different time it is
complicated
that's true i i much prefer education
people should be educated about the good
and bad points of these figures
i'd prefer them to remain anthony
gormley the sculpture the sculpture said
cecil rhodes statue could have been
turned the other way and i just feel
that
universities getting themselves into all
sorts of pickles today it's statues
other other moments it's no platforming
speakers which the government
is also clamping down on i just think
universities need to get on with
teaching
students and uh try and refrain from all
this nonsense okay ally and christina
thank you both